Cryptanalysis, the art and science of breaking cryptosystems
of cracking codes, of trying to figure out how to break these very cool cryptographic algorithms
that we spent all this time talking about. And when I say the art and the science,
that's quite true. It takes a very clever, very devious mind to try and figure out
how to break cryptographic systems. There are two categories of cryptanalysis
that we're going to look at. Cryptanalytical attacks and cryptographic attacks.
In this module, we're going to focus on cryptanalytical attacks.
So when we say cryptanalytical attacks, what do we mean?
What is the primary goal of all cryptanalytical attacks?
And this is actually really important to understand.
Because when you're thinking about these different types of attacks,
if you understand what you're always after, what the primary goal is,
it makes a lot of you understand how you're going about it.
The primary goal of all cryptanalytical attacks is to deduce the key.
Figure out what the key is that's being used in the cryptosystem.
Let's talk about brute force attacks.
Brute force attacks are very simple.
You try every single possible key until you find the right key.
But while they're simple, they're not very effective in modern day cryptography.
Because as soon as you get a key length of a reasonable size,
trying to find the one specific key that you're looking for to brute force a key
is not a realistic type of attack.
So here's an interesting table that we're showing you here.
This shows you a few pieces of information.
The proper name for this first column would be the key length.
It's the number. It's the number of bits and the key.
The second column is showing you the number of keys.
Better name for that would be the key space.
And the third column is telling you the attack time.
Now here's the interesting thing behind this.
This attack time is based on a system that was built in 1999,
specifically to brute force des.
So in 1999, the EFF spent $250,000 to build a system.
Best name system ever, Deepcrack.
So they built a system in 1999 called Deepcrack,
specifically designed to break des and to brute force a des key.
In 1999, it took 20 hours to brute force a des key.
Now, our modern day systems have gotten significantly faster
than what we had in 1999,
orders of magnitude faster.
But even so, it doesn't matter.
So a modern day system could brute force a des key in minutes, maybe hours.
But once you start to increase the key length,
if you increase the key length by even one bit,
what happens to the key space?
It doubles.
And so it grows exponentially.
And by the time we get up to 128-bit,
even especially 256-bit keys,
the concept that you could possibly brute force that key is
completely absurd.
And here's a way to think of that,
to understand how insanely impossible it is to try and brute force
a 256-bit key.
We need to think of some sort of way of wrapping our head around,
just how big is the key space for a 256-bit key?
So here's a way to think about it, okay?
Think about the number of atoms.
So there's a lot of atoms in, say, a person.
Now, when we talk about a 256-bit key,
the key space is 1.15, 1.15 times 10 to the 77th.
That's the key space.
That's a huge number.
How big is that?
Well, if we compare it to the number of atoms,
the number of atoms in the human body is only 10 to the 27th.
Again, we're looking for 10 to the 77th.
No, we're near close.
Okay, well, what about the number of atoms in the earth?
Well, that's only 10 to the 50th.
Again, no, we're near close.
Okay, so what about the number of atoms in the
our solar system, the Sun, Earth, Neptune, Mars,
all the matter in our little solar system?
That's only 10 to the 52nd.
Again, no, we're near close.
You have to actually get up to the entire observable universe.
That's about 10 to the 79th atoms in the entire observable universe.
That's an insanely large number.
When someone says to you, oh, we're going to brute force a 256-bit key,
what they're essentially saying is that they're trying to find one
and only one unique atom in the entire observable universe.
It's insane.
It is totally impossible with modern-day technology to possibly
brute force a 50 to 256-bit key, and it's going to be impossible for quite a ways to go.
So what are reasonable techniques that we could use?
Well, let's go through a few other crypto-analytical attacks.
And again, I'm going to remind you,
the whole point of all these attacks is to deduce the key,
figure out the key.
Now, the first attack we're going to look at is what's known as a
cypher-text-only attack.
And as the name implies, all that the crypto-analysis has access to here,
the only attack is just the cypher-text.
So this is a very difficult type of an attack.
The next is what's known as a plain-text attack.
In a plain-text attack, the crypto-analysis actually has access to the cypher-text
and the plain-text.
So maybe a spy or someone like that smuggled out the plain-text.
They pulled the cypher-text off the wire, so they have access to both.
If the crypto-analysis already has the plain-text and the cypher-text,
why are they doing anything to find the key?
Because with the key, you can decode all the other messages
and perhaps even forge your own messages.
So that's a plain-text attack.
Now, the next two attacks have the word chosen in them.
Here's what chosen means.
Chosen means the crypto-analysis has access to the machine or the algorithm
that's performing the encryption.
And so, in a chosen plain-text attack,
what that means is that the crypto-analysis is able to choose the plain-text
that they feed into the machine or the algorithm,
look at the result in cypher-text to determine, to deduce the key.
Now, with modern algorithms that we use, des AES, so forth,
do we know, do we have access to the algorithms?
And the answer is absolutely yes.
These modern-day algorithms, they're open source.
So think of a chosen plain-text attack as you have access to the AES,
AES algorithm.
You choose what plain-text to feed into it.
You look at the result in cypher-text to try and deduce the key.
The next one is known as a chosen cypher-text.
And as you're probably guessing, a chosen cypher-text attack
is where the crypto-analysis feeds in some cypher-text, some chosen cypher-text.
Looks at the result in plain-text to try and deduce the key.
Now, the next two types of attacks known as linear and differential.
All you should really know about these is they are using complicated math to try and deduce the key.
So you see linear, you see differential, just think, complicated math,
complicated math to try and deduce the key.
And the final one we'll talk about is what's known as a factoring attack.
Now, what is the only algorithm that we talked about that used factoring
as the hard math problem behind it?
RSA.
So if you see factoring as the hard, as a type of an crypto-analytical attack,
the only algorithm that you need to think about is RSA.
So associate those in your mind.